i felt completely helpless
i thought my family would help but
every single ask request
warning whatever it is just got met with
total silence or
total neglect you know you see that that
pain that he builds in the
apple series that he's done when he sits
down once again with
oprah winfrey really to bear his soul
and it's
it makes for pretty heartbreaking
listening i mean many people may feel
they've heard enough of
harry harfon about his mental health but
when you when you listen to him talk
about
what he experienced as a child being his
mother behind the wheel
chased by the paparazzi in tears you
know that's
it it's hard to hear it it shouldn't
have been that way and that's clearly
harry's message and what's also hard to
hear is him say that
he was told to just bury that pain to
get on with that grief when he was a
young boy wasn't able to process what
had happened because
as far as he says diana wasn't talked
about her death
wasn't talked about it was a case of you
know we've got to move on from this
and he says that charles said to him it
was the same for me when i was a child
and
i think that sort of certainly reminds
us of what he said just as recently as
last week in that podcast when he talked
about that
that cycle of genetic pain and he has
said and he reiterates this in the
apples theory if he had to leave britain
he had to leave the royal army for a
better life for himself
and his wife who he said reiterates what
they said in oprah
was suicidal when she was pregnant they
went to the royal family and they
weren't helped
so hard-hitting allegations and claims
from prince harry
i suspect those words recollection may
vary will come up
all over again but this is the prince in
his own words
i mean how significant do you think this
program will be that the me you can't
see because he does
actually accuse his family of of total
neglect
he does jillian he absolutely does and
he brings up those racism claims again
he says my mother was chase
death while in a relationship with
someone who wasn't white now look what's
happening so that
the whole racism element is as well has
been brought into this
um he doesn't seem to want to drop this
um i feel
perhaps he thinks he's not being heard
and that is why he is going to
continually repeat
this narrative he's not letting it go
the problem is
for as long as he chooses not to let it
go i think it makes
any hope of reconciliation both between
himself and his brother
and his father who actually has been
more in the firing line i think than
william
it makes that very difficult indeed
katie nicole thank you for sharing your
views with us uh katie nicholl from
vanity fair raw correspondent